bello e tutti ragazzi e perdere questo
video sono fatti j
e oggi siamo su the sims 4 dite la
verità non l'avreste mai detto è
d'accordo ragazzi dire che facevo
cominciare tra l'altro ho voluto questo
mi è morto davanti all ufficio carcere
che anche se è diversissimo da tutti i
videogiochi che faccio di solito
riferisce fatto che tipo io andavo pazzo
per the sims 2 e quindi praticamente è
rimasta già mi piace sto gioco dice
siccome io andavo andava veramente pazzo
per le 62 quando ero più piccolo non
vedevo l'ora che uscisse il 4 che avevo
uscito da poco quindi ragazzi volevo
assolutamente fare oddio no dai una
figata si possono cambiare così però io
io sarei un maschio in teoria quindi
dovrei sì sì sei molto bella però io
sono maschio do non maschio cioè mi
servirebbe tipo si possono creare anche
i puffi e non capo dio ragazzi è
inquietante da morire mi fa veramente
piacere che tu sia così bella perché
sono un maschio plan
sì l'ho fatta volevo potevo il codice
rosso streaming fine la testa e geniale
va bè ragazzi io spesso a fare un
personaggio decente senza lo voglio lo
voglio azzurro abbiate pazienza questo
assicura la si può essere il nome anche
ciao mi chiamo come cazzo lo chiama
facciamo gustavo dai gustavo gustavo la
patata pistola per fare questo mi piace
questa
ok non è prima fatemi vedere un attimo
che cosa posso meteo mio che ben
bizzarria ragazzi di punto all degli
alla barba rosa 9 questa mi mancava
ragazzi voglio fare tutto più strano
bossi oddio marega fermi fermi fermi che
ho avuto l'ispirazione è lui è lui è lui
con una cresta però direi che ci stiamo
avvicinando più o meno ma se tipo in
chirurgia o cose del genere però ci devo
riuscire che se riesco a 6 riesco a far
shrek basta voglio essere imperatore del
mondo
non ci possono dai sono troppo un genio
o mio dio mi chiamo sarah in boxer non
si può vedere ragazzi perfetto ragazzi
cioè va dai basta ci sia me e lui
gustarne jacques chirac la patata questo
ragazzi era era schleck da piccolo sono
rivelazioni questa che ha sconvolto
un'infanzia sta cosa basso cioè stile di
camminata prefinito ragazzi credo che la
mia vita dopo questo sia completa sono
un [ __ ] genio perfetto ragazzi direi
che ci siamo
altro fatto padre madre e figlio anche
se non ci somiglia una sega
io non so come ti posso anche fiona
abbiano fatto ad avere un buffo e né
tantomeno mi interessa però la famiglia
la patata la patata è bellissimo stato
mezz'ora mettere a posto personaggi però
che bella famiglia tra il trasferimento
di la patata perfetto tacita speriamo
sorprendente l'unico che posso scegliere
ragazza e questo perché ammobiliati la
facciamo così è l'unico che posso
permettermi per ora però sono convinto e
alla famiglia la patata ce la farà a
prendersi una villa
forse era meglio la palude assumere con
roche ragazzi allora io non gioco the
sims la qualcosa come 10 anni però va
beh allora vai qui perfetto fatto i miei
primi passi che non sta facendo quindi
perfetto a no perché c'è la pausa
perfetto come si fa a mettere non è così
ok si si si si lo so io so giocare
meglio di chiunque altro non voglio fare
il tutorial a via se riesco a fare una
roba decente cambiali tale non dirmi
cosa devo fare muro n io faccio quello
che voglio ma che carini quello che
cazzo ragazzi è una cosa meravigliosa
che padre e figlio facciano che poi non
ho capito perché lui e lui e blu e gli
altri son birdie ma non importa
fu grazie alla fine figlio l'ho chiamato
ho chiamato lui gustavo gustavo la
patata al mi piace come nome madonna che
televisori in full hd 3d ragazzi c'è
troppo effetti staff a mickey mezzo fa
al bambino
ma questo non è normale si può comprare
qualcosa che sta casa non ci fa una
mazza di niente ragazzi io non so come
giocare abbiate pazienza questo sto
parlando il baseball scatta una famiglia
che si fanno i sensi non ci serio che
figata regalato due amici che stavo bene
ma vabbè dopo quest'anno i ragazzi dopo
questa decisa il mio gioco preferito in
assoluto poi i figli figo dio si possono
già fare cose oscene non siamo neanche
partiti né accetterà mai ha detto sì
ragazzi ha detto sì però non me la
faccio vedere sta cosa perchè è brutta
noi guardiamo la televisione col bambino
in laminati con questa cosa è brutta o
mio dio mio dio che cosa o mio dio ha
scritto
io non me li posso immaginare più nel
rack che nella palude loro credo ragazzi
stanno facendo cose alquanto strana cosa
sta succedendo il bambino si guarda tv
tranquilli colino mia vieni a vedere che
sta facendo molto di un regalo
traumatizzò ragazzi sto per
traumatizzare un bambino tenetevi forte
europa già facciamo la facciamo
oh cazzo meno male che ha finito in
tempo hai visto mamma e papà che fanno
stanno dormendo poi non è che poi
comporti un po pettino non lo so
[Musica]
ragazze è una cosa alquanto strana però
mi sa che shrek e non c'e non ci sa fare
con le donne credo perché imbarazzato il
bambino che cazzo successo ha visto la
perché ha visto i genitori vabbè dai
nomi per non sembra tanto sta andando al
contrario no che schifo non puoi
controllare quello che spero vivamente
che le lenzuola siano pulite ragazzi a
parte che shayk ci prova con tutte ma
non importa cosa diavolo ti sei perso
amico mio massimo si può andare in giro
a vedere cosa succede da qualche parte
non lo so e sismico a si può fare
perfetto ok posso andare a far casino in
casa degli altri fantastico cioè io
voglio vedere chi è che apra un bambino
che sembra un puffo ma ma va bene così
ciao bella bambina presentazione
scortese c'è questi entrano in casa
degli altri come se niente fosse un po
vediamo non posso fare per essere
cattivo il più possibile derivi urla
contro di che la mamma e un l'arma
io posso dirgli che sua mamma è un lama
jay o amo questo gioco ragazzi basta
ovviamente il bambino si addormenta è
vero perché non c'è letto per il bambino
non ho previsto un letto per il bambino
che si faranno a me sondando la ma si è
svegliata e guarda la tv
a mezzanotte giusto all una e mezza di
notte questi continuano magari se vai a
dormire un po mail niente questi non
vanno a dormire questi alle due litigano
che cosa fa questa è uscita cos'è quel
coso sta facendo perché ha buttato a
terra all'immondizia iniziata a
calpestare roba ragazzi ma sta famiglia
è normale tuttavia gioca dentro a
giocare l'immondizia ovvia se è certo
che ha certo mi sembra ovvio che io amo
studi su ciò che la cosa più bella che
abbiamo ovviamente quella butta giù la
immondizia poi si fa la doccia
fantastico e non è bastato l'accappatoio
dice
è un peccato ragazzi perché volevo
vedere fiona il lavoro di film ma che
cazzo è perché ragazzi perché voglio
vedere fiona che diavolo ma perché ti
metti a fare pressioni in mezzo alla
strada figlia mia
adesso falli però visto che sei in
palestra si può estiva importunare la
gente oddio ma questa non è la palestra
e un ristorante che cazzo alle docce
contattato sembra un morto vivente
questo contro cammina videogiochi mica
sembra uno zombie che voglia vuole
giocare video games tipo questo dorme
sui divani ragazzi già dei problemi seri
credo ragazzi qualcosa mi dice che si
sta cadendo addosso gustavo per ora
tutto è ok forse si è si è già cagato
addosso in casa un pazzo scalmanato in
camere in casa mia e l'hai trovato
perfetto schiaccio mandano via
ma cosa ragazzi se lo sta portando a
letto c'è un tizio che non conosciamo in
salotto non so se qualcuno vuole andare
a controllare
niente questo si fa i cazzi suoi come
gustavo fai qualcosa per l'amor di dio
fai qualcosa non socializzare con le mie
colori do il mio avvio devi insultarlo e
dirgli di andare via subito lamentati
dei miei problemi no parlare di
giocattoli che sua madre non lava forza
ok ok potrebbe essere una cosa brutta
ragazzi gori vai vai ragazzi già deve
fare ce la deve fare veloce mica che
zombie ragazzi la vita di stop amino
saper essere sconvolta ce l'ho fatta
c'è
ma che poi quando giocava the sims 2
quando ero più piccolo tipo io non
sapevo lista cosa dei bisogni trovato
sai cucinare da dio shrek fattelo dire
se vuole provare a uccidere un sì ma in
qualche modo ci voglio provare almeno
una volta nel frattempo se riuscite a
datevi dei consigli nei commenti su come
potrei ammazzare un sim in qualche modo
so che sono persi vedete più bella che
mi date ragazzi nel prossimo episodio
proverò a farle quindi direi che posso
concludere qui per questo episodio
seguito è piaciuto ma se il documento mi
piace anche a pacciani facebook e come
non i video trovate nella descrizione
però se dovessi descrivermi il ci
vediamo un prossimo video della ragazza